ne olur
[Müzik]
abone ol
Selam
gençler ritim dinleyici lerimizi
sevgiyle selamlıyorum Ben bugün sizlerle
üç küçük hikaye paylaşmak istiyorum
mesafe konuşuyoruz bir tanesi Adana'da
denize koşan deniz kaplumbağası hikayesi
diğeri Endonezya ve blasten müjde haberi
gelen karaya vuran balinanın hikayesi
bir Sonuncusu da bu han'daki şu meşhur
tezgahları düşen yarasalı hikayesi Evet
bugün mesafe konuşuyoruz
yaşamlarının büyük bir çoğunluğunu
mesafe kat ederek geçiren deniz
kaplumbağası mı hikayesini anlatmak
istiyorum 100 milyon yıldır bu dünyada
lar Aslında en eski denizcilerden onlar
100.000 yumurtadan sadece bir tanesi
hayata tutulabiliyor önce karadaki
zorlukları geçmeleri gerekiyor gerek
yırtıcı kuşlar gerek tüm bunlara
takılmadan ya da ışıkların yanlış
yönlendirmesine gitmeden denize
ulaştıktan sonra eğer yem olmayı
başarabilirler
st25 yaşında geldiklerinde doğdukları
kıyıya geri dönüp yumurta bırakıyorlar
bizim bir uydudan takip ettiğimiz bir
deniz kaplumbağa mız var Evet ismim Baba
Burada gördüğünüz gibi Adana'dan yola
çıktı kilometrelerce yol gitti geçti
Afrika Kuzey Afrika kıyılarına ulaştı
Mısır kıyılarında yolculuğuna devam
ediyor bu niye bizim için önemli bu
yolculuk boyunca Deniz çayırları yiyor
karşısında denizanaları çıktığında da
onları afiyetle çekiyor Deniz
çayırlarının çok çok önemli bizim için
Çünkü Deniz çayırları Aslında
denizlerimize oksijen veren bitkiler
Deniz kaplumbağaları sonları Yedikçe
biçiyorlar ve çoğaltıyorlar ve
böylelikle yeni çayı larımızın artmasına
vesile oluyorlar bir bu çoğunlukla
denizlerimizi oksijen karbon tutam
kaynaklarımız olarak görmeyi hep
ormanları konuşuruz ama denizlerimizde
Aslında havayı temizleyen çok önemli bir
kaynağımız Dolayısıyla bizim malın
yediği Deniz çayırları bitki Deniz
çayırları Mısır'da başına gelenler Belki
bir deniz kaplumbağası diye deniz anası
sanarak gibi bir plastik poşet Sadece
bizim değil hepimizin ortak meselesi
Çünkü Soluduğumuz hava temiz havanın
içinde çok önemli bir payı var şimdi
mesafeler konuşuruz bir de okyanusların
öbür tarafına gidelim bize Endonezya'dan
gelen haberi paylaşmak istiyorum sizinle
görüntüler biraz rahatsız edici Bunun
için özür diliyorum ama paylaşmak
zorundaydım bu balina Pasifik
okyanusu'nda serbestçe gezerken Hint
Okyanusu ile Pasifik Okyanusu arasında
da 59 fark bu iki katı gıda sanarak
tuttu 20 kilogram toplamı bunun içinde
plastik bahçe hortumu sprey kutusu seri
yapımında kullanılan Plastikler poşetler
vardı ve karaya oturdu ikinci hangi
ülkede Hangi bahçede
Belki de çok Naif çekerek olan bir
plastik olduğun parçası hangi dilde
ulaştı hangi denize ulaştı ve okyanusta
Bu yüzden de bayrağının ölümüne sebep
oldu aslında Sadece kendisi değil
plastik bir tam Bizlerde çöpünüzü yer
olduk
mikroplastikler o küçük 5 milimden ufak
olan doğaya karışan mikroplastikler
İçtiğimiz su da yediğimiz yemekte
Soluduğumuz havada son çıkan bir
araştırmaya göre b haftada hepimiz
istisnasız 5 gram ya bir kredi kartı
büyüklüğünde lastik tüket O bize her yıl
8 milyon ton plastik denizlerimize
karışıyor ve 2050 yılında benzerini de
balıktan çok plastik olacağı öngörülüyor
bu da başka bir yerdeki başka uzak bir
mesafede ki balinanın hikayesi Şimdi
gelelim bizim şu meşhur yarasaya hop
aleminde birçok insan benim yakın
çevremde Bir de Yarasa Günah Keçisi
seçme eğilimi deydi şimdi hatta içinde
dava açalım diyenler bile oldu
yara sayımız çoğunlukla görmüyoruz asla
Yarasalar biliyorsunuz geceleri ortalığa
çıkıyorlar ve her gece onlarca yüzlerce
böcek yiyorlar böyle Aslında çiftçilerin
çok büyük bir yükünü sırtından alıyorlar
çok daha az tarım zehirlisi kullanıyor
Yarasalar sayesinde
fakat biz onların yaşam alanına
girdiğimizde ormansızlaşma bu yol yapmak
için
madencilikle veya onları tüketmek için
anladığımızda şurada doğanın dengesini
bozmuş oluyoruz Onlar hiç karşılaşmadığı
canlılarla karşılaşıyorlar yaşam
alanlarından çıkmak zorunda kalıyorlar
hastalığını yorlar ve
onların da bünyesinde olan bazı virüsler
hastalığa dönüşüyor Bu hastalıkları
yapmaya başlıyorlar bugün Yarasalar
Yarın Koalalar Aslı bu istediği son On
senede salgın hastalıkların 3 kadar
artmasının sebebi hesabı üste değil
domuz gribi ve kuş gibi bir ebola marsar
servis Stars hepsi aynı sebebe dayanıyor
O da bizim evin çok uzun zamandır doğal
felaketi üzerine Saadet kurma hayalim
sizden kaynaklanıyor
bütün bu hikayeler gösteriyor ki Aslında
bizim kalbi Kafamızda yarattığımız
silahlar bu düşünce şekli bu mesafelerin
doğal Bu yaşlı yok O nasıl olduğu hava
benim sorduğumda Onun duası benim basın
diye Doğan değişiyor mu ve biz bu
Kolektif düşünmeyi başaramadığınız için
toplumlar olarak kolektif bir
başarısızlık yaşıyoruz
Bizler Tabii başın çok içindeyiz gece
gündüz bu rakamları o Köz belki Sizlerde
bu işin ciddiyetinin farkında mısınız
ama ben yine de bunu bir tekrarlamak
istiyoruz Dünyamız son 120 yılda 1.2
derece Daha fazla ısındı omurgalı Türk
popülasyonu son 50 Yıl'da da aslında
yani ben doğduğumdan beri temel olarak
168 yok oldu düşünebiliyor musunuz
havada on kuş varken şu anda üç buçuk
var ve bu büyük bir hızla yok olmaya
devam ediyoruz 10 milyon hektar orman
alanı yok oldu ormanların küresel olarak
ormanların yüzde kırkın yok oldu ve biz
de Sabir ne olmuş yaşıyoruz
Peki şimdi bu kadar mesafeleri konuştu
Kolektif başarısızlık konuştu Ama ben
bütün bu hikayenin içinde yine de
tünelin sonunda 31 Işıklı görüyorum
insanlık Aslında büyük Başarılarını
başarısızlıklarından çıkarmış
başarısızlık en büyük insanlığın karşısı
olmuş tarihte pek çok zorlandığı
dönemlerde gelişme ihtiyacı olmuş ve ben
bu döneminde böyle bir değişme ve
gelişme vesile olmasını buluyorum çoğu
zaman şunu soruyorum insanlar bireyler
ya o kadar büyük bir sorun içindeyiz ki
ve ben birey olarak Kendimi çok çaresiz
hissediyorum Ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum
bir kurban psikolojisine Girdim Ne
yapabilirim
ben de şunu söylüyorum şimdi çok şey
yapıyorsunuz biliyorum özel haklarınızda
yapıyorsunuz herkesin başlangıç noktası
farklı fakat Ben hiçbir şey
yapmıyorsanız bile önce kendi küçük
ayaklarımıza bakarak başlayabiliriz yani
sabah uyandığımızda akşam yatana kadar
hayat tarzımızı sorgulayarak
başlayabiliriz Belki bizim görmediğimiz
sizin bildiğiniz bambaşka değişimleri de
vesile olabilir bu sorgulama Yeter ki
bünyemizde o günü Açalım benim de bu
değişim yolculuğu böyle başladı etrafına
başka bir bakmaya başladım ne
yapabilirim diye bakmaya başladım ve
birçok Başında Bir Cumartesi akşamı
oturarak ve izleyerek değişim yolculuğu
başladı o kadar da zor değil ya bir
Great hayırlısını 16 yaşında bir genç
bütün dünyaya meydan okuyor Siz bir
GTA'da olabilirsiniz ya da belki yarın
itibariyle kahve alırken matara ile
olmaya başlayarak bir plastik atık daha
yaratmak yerine bataryayla yolculuğa
çıkabilirsiniz daha az tüketerek daha az
et tüketerek bir
Evet haklısın gerek bisiklete binerek
daha fazla toplu taşıma kullanarak bir
yolculuğa çıkabilirsiniz ya da biraz
daha ileri götürüp değişimi el
verebilirsiniz yolculukta olanların
yanında olmayı seçebilirsiniz yada
Yanlışlıkla ses verebilirsiniz internet
gibi bir mekanizmalar var zam değişim
gücü vardı bu devletin 12 yaşında
Brezilya'da bir gence verdiği dünya
gençlik ödülünde hepimize ayakta
alkışlatan yüz ülkenin başkanları bir
ara derken hepimizi ayakta bir şey
söyledi 12 yaşında bir genci
internetteki değişim hücre asla küçük
Sevin dedi Ve gerçekten kendi bölgesinde
büyük bir değişik yarattı bir imza
kampanyası ile 400 bin kişiler imza
toplayarak doğanın katledilmesine engel
oldu bu Bu değişme ses verebilirsiniz ev
verebilirsiniz alep edebilirsiniz
değişiklikler oy verirsiniz ya da belki
de ileride çok büyük bir değişime
yaratacak sosyal bir girişimin
tohumlarını bugün atmaya
başlayabilirsiniz düşünmeye
başlayabilirsiniz harekete
geçebilirsiniz fakat atmıyorum ki
dileğim odur ki her ne yaparsanız yapın
bugün itibariyle yapmaya başlayın bu
yolculukta varsanız bir adım daha ileri
atın yoksanız Biz gemiye katılım Çünkü
çok kritik bir dönemdeyiz önünüzde bir
10 sene bir değişim dönemi var buz
Burada doğru adımları yaparsa bu büyük
Kolektif
başarısızlıktan büyük bir başarı
hikayesi Hep birlikte yaratabiliriz çok
teşekkür ediyorum